many recruiters will block out times in
their Diaries to do particular tasks I'm
going to spend two hours doing business
development but what does that actually
mean for example I'm going to build a
project of at least 30 great candidates
within this hour-long period and they're
all getting the first message set small
tangible goals that will set you on your
way to your weekly kpi or Target that's
how we do that and that's how I keep
myself accountable moving forward
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Hisham azuz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Lewis Gadsden
who has built out a successful career
over the last seven or so years at wiser
Elite now before that he was destined to
become an actor but after giving it a
real go he kick-started his recruitment
career with a point to prove at 25 years
old and hasn't looked back since we dug
into so much on this episode from how
he's gone about mastering the player
coach role how he manages his time to
perform and get the best out of his team
how he went about holding the top
performer title back to back what good
BD strategies look like and so much more
enjoy the episode Lewis welcome to the
podcast cheers mate thank you thanks for
coming in yeah thanks for having me what
do you think of the space it's awesome
it's good it's like a proper
professional setup I'm not saying you
wouldn't have been professional before
but this is next level yeah I mean it
definitely wasn't always this started on
the mobile phone in the bedroom mate so
um yeah but really looking forward to
this like I've really enjoyed our
conversations interactions I know that
you came to the live podcast event yeah
last year and these types of things so
I think really excited to talk about
this journey that you've been on Plenty
to unpack plenty to learn from so I
guess like
um I always like to do
on these uh episodes it just just give
some immediate context uh in terms of
where is Lewis on his recruitment
Journey yeah so we're just saying that
you've been uh in the game the
recruitment game now for nearly seven
years yeah and I think what I found
really interesting is that for a lot of
that time you've been in a player
manager role since 2018 yeah so player
manager being the you're someone that is
still very much hitting a number
performing but also then uh responsible
for managing a team getting the most out
of them these types of things right yeah
cool so I think some of the key things
that we we put down here so you've
always I know it's sort of sometimes
fluctuated or whatever but I think
you've always ended up leading and
managing a team of around five people
yeah four to five people four to five
people right and that is that where
you're at right now yeah currently
managing a team of four four or five
myself included yeah okay awesome
um and I think one of the things quite
notably is so 2019
2020 yeah Lewis kept hold of the top
performer title at wiser
and your best year uh Billings wise has
been 380 Grand and obviously bearing in
mind that's whilst being in the player
manager wrong yeah right yeah so loads
to unpack here we're going to talk about
leadership we're going to be talking
about
Business Development time management
because I know that's something that
you're you're known for building
communities because I know that's
something that you guys have done really
successfully but where we always like to
start is a million pound question so I'd
love to get your Tech Lewis what are the
common characteristics and traits that
you believe make up a highly successful
recruiter in in today's market let's
start there well I'll I'll tell you what
I normally look for when when hiring
someone first and foremost you need to
be a bit nuts and by that I mean in a
sense of you have to be comfortable
not fully being in control if you're a
control freak recruitment is probably
gonna come hard at you so you can always
have your process you can literally nail
the preparation you can nail your
messaging you can nail your registering
you're qualifying your CV sends all of
that sort of thing but at the end of the
day you cannot do an interview for your
candidate recruitment is one of the only
businesses in the world where your
product has emotions it has finances the
weather relationships
Sports pets whatever all of that sort of
thing which can knock it on any one
given day and it all comes down to a
human impressing another human over a
course of half an hour or an hour which
is madness
absolutely mad so if you're a control
freak
you got no hope so that's the first
thing that I look out for second thing I
would say and in my current team under
like current regime everyone's got this
in some capacity
they need they need to make it work
in recruitment they need to make it work
there needs to be an Underdog Story or
something going against them a point to
prove a chip on the shoulder not to like
immediately make it all about me but
when when I started in recruitment I was
25 and I was a bit older than most uh I
was a failed actor yeah my girlfriend
lived in London I was living back home
with my parents in Norfolk we were on
completely different working schedules
because I was doing hospitality jobs to
support myself and also my degree wasn't
worth the paper it was written on
because guess what I did a degree in
acting so all of that sort of thing
stacked up against me and when an
opportunity like wiser came knocking and
I managed to to get that foot in the
door
I was going to move hell on Earth to
make it work because I needed to I
wanted a better life for myself and
that was it and then from there God
bless my in-laws they live in Oxford
they took me in as well pretty much rent
free so I'll never forget that and I
commuted for 10 months from Oxford three
hours 20 minutes every day to add insult
to injury the train times didn't really
align either so I'd either end up being
five minutes late into the office or 40
minutes early
so guess what 40 minutes early every day
um and we did that for 10 months until
basically we've got enough uh got
ourselves into a good enough position to
to start renting a place me and my
girlfriend who's now my wife so that's
amazing all worked out pretty well in
the end but taking it back to the
question something to prove that's what
we need there's there's one person in my
team who slept on a sofa for nine months
and he's now one of our top performers
like you know what I mean that sort of
behavior those characteristics that you
need to be successful in the recruitment
because it's not easy and it's
definitely not the best paid to start
off with hmm
love that I'd probably say what I'd add
to that I don't know what you think but
you're not saying that you need to have
that to be successful right but it can
damn help if it's something that I
automatically look out for yeah of
course you don't need to be I know some
excellent recruiters that you know on
the face of things did not need to make
it work or did not need to make it work
in any way shape or form but
and I'm not saying you need to be as
Extreme as how I did it and have
everything stacked against you but look
it helps sure it helps and helps me make
a decision so I have to ask because when
when you said it I was like oh really
like talk to me about this acting
Journey mate like what what did we learn
from it what what was most difficult
that you was most surprised by yeah like
yeah obviously that was like you said
I don't know what we're going to call it
like the one I guess that would have
been the challenging period right
because I'm assuming you would have sort
of been telling people that I'm an actor
I'm going to be an act of these things
and then there would have been a moment
where you're like yeah this I'm not
sure this is actually who I'm gonna be
and then obviously recruitment's ended
up giving you an awesome opportunity and
you've made the most out of it but what
did we learn from that acting period
yeah I I look back at it as a bit of a
quarter life crisis not not gonna lie
but
um growing up as a kid like it was
always what I was going to do it was
always what I was going to do I was like
locally known for like amtran
performances doing all those sorts of
things in the local paper for doing it
my high school was a performing arts
college as well it was just it was meant
to be written in the stars for me I mean
it was going to happen and you know what
I literally gave it my all but all my
eggs in that basket and obviously then
went on to UNI did that got my acting
degree and I worked for two years solely
and so I was 25 when I started
recruitment I worked for two and a bit
years solely supporting myself with
acting work did okay don't be wrong
hadn't moved out still lived at home for
the most part but I was going on tours
and doing all that stuff
any stories
really yeah a couple of adverts and uh
yeah a couple of theater tours which
were which which was great yeah but then
I just always find myself at the end of
each job just being like
I need structure I need structure and I
expect I can be working harder like in
acting it's funny so many people want to
do it but so many people just end up
waiting around for the phone to ring
their agents are cool and
it was yeah it was fine but I was always
actively seeking work and I got to the
point where I was like I'm out working
my agent here and trying to get myself
different jobs and I was doing jobs that
weren't glamorous I was doing jobs that
you know might have been looked down
upon by the upper echelon of actors but
guess what I was supporting myself as an
actor weirdest job that you've done huh
where this job that you've done uh is I
would say it's a weirdest job but we we
I did like I had I had a steady gig in
in acting which was doing theater in
education so touring around schools and
whatnot that's quite funny walk past
Central Foundation school this morning
just near XO yo over there I was like
not only have I been in XO yo I've also
taught
so it was uh it was quite funny but I
did that and that was a steady gigging
between the the better more glamorous
job should we say but look I just I took
stock when
like this would have been 20 2016 and
like I said I was doing hospitality jobs
in the interim of not acting
um and
my girlfriend was working nine to five
office I was working evening and
weekends it was long distance didn't
work it was put massive strain on it and
I was just like I just expect more for
my life I expect more I can be doing
more I can work harder than this and
that's when I just had the Epiphany I'm
like right okay
Now's the Time yeah
put that uh put that on the back burner
and see where we end up and focus on
making sure we've got a good trajectory
first now the way you talk about that I
think we can implies to recruitment
right and I'm sure you've had people
maybe in your team or whatever but I
think there's nothing wrong with being
able to look in the mirror and go you
know what I've given it my all and maybe
this isn't white whatever and you can
you can absolutely apply that to
recruitment but the real question is did
you give it your all you know yeah um so
no I had to ask and it is really
interesting to say that I
um
I had a
um I always like to have conversations
in saunas at the gym and there's a guy
that I spoke to as an actor and I was
like we spoke about it and he said about
the things that you said and it I feel
like there's quite a lot of jobs like
that so I'd say like personal trainer
yeah you might get into it because you
love Fitness in these things but it's
sales like you're not getting
any you're not getting any clients
unless you've got and speak to them and
go have you got these problems have you
got these challenges but like if you
just expect if you think I'm gonna
become a PT and then I'm going to get
clients it doesn't work like that and it
was sort of the same that this guy was
sent around acting so I'm not surprised
you're saying that it's a lot oh I don't
just like get to do amazing jobs that I
really like I actually have to do BD and
like Network and speak to people and
like there's there's a lot to it isn't
there so it's just it's just interesting
you you saying that um so let so just to
to frame it up then so I think you said
that
early on so you've pretty much done sort
of you've only hired and done sdrs only
yeah I think you put here what from 2021
was it before then yeah from January
2021 we solely focused on sdrs because
that was when uh me and Lauren my team
at the time moved across to wise really
but before that was wiser graduates
um but my team was always textiles so we
were doing entry level positions into
customer success account management sdrs
uh inside sales all of those sorts of
things but it was always Tech focused
always sales focused and but
predominantly entry level so it's
typically entry level right yeah
um so talking about looking back then
what what were some of the like you
clearly had the point to prove yeah we
wanted to make it work you were
committed
so you clearly got to a point where you
could support yourself and and your
partner 10 months in yeah like how how
difficult was the early period like
looking back like anything stand out in
terms of what was extremely difficult
what were some of the biggest challenges
that you had to work through overcome
early on what did Lewis had to to really
work on to make sure that you didn't
then fail at recruitment
if you don't mind I'll frame it as in a
sense of like what I would yeah what I
tell old Lewis yeah lift it up yeah
let's do that so first and foremost
you're gonna build 14k in your first
month you're not sick at recruitment
right yeah you're not sick at
recruitment you haven't worked it out
you're not some sort of recruitment
Prodigy you're gonna go the next eight
weeks and you're gonna build all
okay you're gonna build Buckle there's
gonna be moths flying around your name
on the money board and all that sort of
Don't worry
um it's all going to work out all right
at the end but um the first first
tangible bit of advice that I'd probably
give is
build out relevant LinkedIn connections
early
so your LinkedIn page is like
your shop front yeah if you have a
couple of hundred to a thousand
connections on LinkedIn
your your shop front is effectively I
don't know
Millie's cookies Ben's cookies whatever
normally a little stand I love my little
pants cookies but they're like little
little stands right whereas in actual
fact we get start getting into the tens
of thousands and all that sort of thing
we're talking Sports Direct or
selfridges like you know I mean you want
people browsing your shop in hopefully
hoping to buy so that that is the first
thing I wish I'd have done early doors
and that's what I tell my team to do
from now on be on your phone it actually
works better on the LinkedIn app it's
actually made connections with people as
opposed to doing it on your desktop so
if you want to build a search of
relevant people in your market so if
you're a recruiter obviously ours was
like sdrs sales directors heads of sales
go on the LinkedIn app build a search
there and you can actually just hit them
one touch connections really yeah when
you've got the search on yeah obviously
there's now a massive limit as what you
can do is 100 100 a week or something
like that didn't used to be like that
but still those connection requests
should be topped up all the time making
sure you're in the shop window for
people to see what the hell you're up to
and start and start writing you I'd
I'd also say
the the biggest thing you can do is
actually invest in relationships early
build relationships the best recruiters
I've seen do not facilitate
transactions in this case placements you
know you don't just take the brief
find the candidate send it place it
thank you very much see you later and
don't get to actually invest in your
client or know them my first taste of
this so mum's a hairdresser dad's a
fruit and veg man on great yarm of
marketplace have you ever been to Great
Yarmouth I'm sorry it wasn't me
um but in that vicinity and this is this
is where I came to realize that quite
early on my dad had a fruit and
vegetable but a four rather fruit and
vegetables Within 100 of each other okay
and my dad's was always the busiest
and you rack your brains and I'm like
well why was always the busiest you're
not selling any different fruit any
different veg
prices are probably a little bit higher
than the rest there's no real difference
but yeah people are queuing up to to
speak to my dad and and buy their fruit
and veg from him and not go into the
other four stalls and it was because my
dad invested in people people didn't
come to the stall to buy fruit and veg
that was a byproduct they came to have a
conversation with my dad because even
when they were walking past and not
buying anything he was always shouting
people saying hello having a little
interaction with them ask them about
them invest in it it's almost like
therapy for some people I think they
used to come to the store especially
like lonely older people they were like
absolutely adamant that they would go to
my dad's for his fruit and veg and it's
exactly the same in recruitment I
encourage my team to always spend time
with people that can that can help them
not in a selling capacity
so for example you know and it's a
little bit strange to people especially
in the beginning when they're a bit
Junior and it's like
what you mean we're going to go for a
meeting we're gonna go meet hish but
we're not gonna have a client briefing
but we're not gonna try and sell to him
or all of that sort of thing I'm like no
we're gonna go for dinner we're gonna go
for a beer
you know we're or anything like that I'm
just going to catch up and shoot the
like that's it that's it and then
if you can't focus on that the rest of
it comes when the time's right the rest
of it comes people do not like to be
sold to so yeah invest in relationships
early
um and and probably the last bit of
advice that I'd give is
chill the out
is that it's never as it's Never As Good
As It Seems it's never as bad as it
seems what my granddad always used to
say Never As Good As It Seems never as
bad as it
the it I'll share it but I've never
I've never really told anyone but
my granddad actually passed away the day
before my final interview at wiser oh
wow it was expected it was expected so
it doesn't make it any easier but it was
expected and
then obviously it was a bit like right
okay what do I do here do I cancel this
will I still go yeah yeah do I cancel
this interview or you know more out of
respect or anything like I said it was
expected but at the same time saying
that phrase
It's Never As Good As It Seems they're
as bad as it seems and then
going back to that sheer want that need
to make it work he wouldn't wanted me to
pass up the opportunity me not knowing
he's not going to bring it back so maybe
in this case not as bad as it seems
Optima Car went to London got the job
and here we are nearly seven years later
so it was the right decision so and and
whenever it gets high or low in
recruitment whenever we're doing like I
mentioned in our prep 18 months ago
obviously things are going great like
literally it's awesome but again never
get too high it's Never As Good As It
Seems and in the past six months where
it's been a little bit tougher I've had
to work much harder it's never as bad as
it seems yeah and I think it's so these
sort of little simple phrases mantras
are like just so useful uh to have you
know so no thank you for sharing that
and I think that that is a great one
it's Never As Good As It Seems as bad as
it seems that is uh that that definitely
can help me when I have wobbles or these
types of things it's and I think it's
just as important as you just said when
it is really good yeah you know to
remember because typically it's like
really want to hear like how do you deal
with the bad times what's like how do
you deal with the good times
because if you're just going out
spending all your money yeah getting
really
um high on the highs then you're gonna
come crashing down that's even more
challenging yeah what I wanted to ask
you on the building relationships piece
just quickly was I I really buy into
that like I've sort of I don't know what
it was but I just sort of bought into
that quite early in terms of like I just
believe in in business Karma I just do
or like just good karma in general yeah
like I just always feel like if you give
more than than um if you yeah if you
give more than you get it just always
plays out right but that can be hard
sometimes when you've got a manager
going Lewis you haven't made the dolls
this week or what you're just meeting
that person and you you're not working
with them you know it's it's hard to
juggle so I guess my my question for you
on that is what are some of the lagging
indicators that we can keep an eye on
that can make you feel like well no like
this is starting to pay dividends and it
is going in the right direction because
I'm sure this is what you maybe try and
highlight with your team when you're
like no look this is is this will play
out and and it will play out what are
some of the lagging indicators of yeah
it sort of reinforcing that no building
relationships not being transactional is
going to massively happen in the long
run are there any lagging indicators
that sometimes you sort of pick out or
get a sense of or sometimes have your
team recognized to make them feel
confident no this is going to play out
in the long run yeah no absolutely I
mean
it's not a tangible thing but it is a
feeling like it is a feeling you know
for well if you get along well with
someone like you know what I mean you
know for what if they rate you and they
rate what you do and they rate your
service the key thing is always making
sure okay looking at the long-term
vision is this going to go somewhere
like at any one time can we identify a
time where this will be beneficial
doesn't always need to be beneficial
like a lot of my clients I actually you
know they've turned friends and I
actually just enjoy spending time with
them I go meeting for a beer like do I
mean it's absolutely fine but you know
there always does need to be that thing
in the backing mind of look don't sell
to them straight away don't think that
you need to come back after one meeting
bang rolls retainer or anything like
that but just know that at some point it
can get there it can get there it's the
right person and that's that's another
thing as well which I'd probably not to
jump around a bit but advise to to liver
seven years ago is identify your
Champions early especially when you're
placing in a more entry-level Market
they are the leaders of three years time
four years time five years time whatever
else it may be but for example there's a
number of sdrs that I placed in my first
year that have now are now heads of
sales they're now decision makers they
now have clout uh to bring us in and do
that and if you keep hold of those
relationships and don't just treat it
like a fee actually treat them like
relationships friendships
now and again you're in that shop window
you're in Prime position in that shop
window and and that's that's something
that we definitely take forward so yeah
that that would be sort of the
indicators for me yeah no that's that's
fair I know I know sometimes it is it
can be quite hard to be it can be quite
hard to sort of have like tangible
things but I wanted to ask so let's get
into Lewis being on top performer then
sure so when what was your what year was
your best year then 2019 on 2020 2020
2020 yeah
so let's firstly talk about 2019.
um what what were some of the things
that you think you did very well that
year to to get the top performance but
as we all know it's it's very
competitive externally but it's very
competitive internally yeah right so
getting the top performance sport is is
absolutely something to be to be proud
of maybe let's start with business
development because I feel like that is
particularly right now that is something
that a lot of people are on a journey
with find it more difficult yeah in 2019
get the first time to be the top
performer like what is it that Lewis did
really well on the BD side what what
played out
um what do you do really well yeah good
so
um the key thing that we don't to be
honest with you there wasn't that there
wasn't like much
tangible
changes that I made in 2019 on the BD
front but there were things that we
started introducing like for example
Partnerships and we started refining our
messaging like that's that's been the
key thing there but with
to put it into a tangible thing with
with actual messaging like we always
look back at then this is Kyle Coleman
this is a tech sales thing the five by
five by five rule so five minutes of
research on a prospect try and get five
key insights and then spend five minutes
actually writing the message
I mean don't spend any longer on it so
you've got personalization you've got
um key insights that they would find
interesting that are probably
personalized to them and introduce us
into the job table and then and then
obviously send thereafter and that
was pretty revolutionary in a sense of
changing the How We messaged people back
then because it was just like a
bombardment of full
messages this is what we do here's a
full catalog here's our deck here's what
we do and it's just a completely
overwhelming with an actual fact short
sharp personalized messages were were
much better but that's something we
started introducing then whether that
was completely pivotal to me being the
top biller in 2019 I'm not sure but it
was something that we started yeah and I
love that that's a great show so the
five minutes yeah so like if I go on
Lewis and he's in my idol client profile
yeah I'll do a customer profile even
obviously candidate as well I'm assuming
five minutes of looking at his profile
what insights can I get what has he been
talking about recently that I can
potentially use in my message then you
said what five minutes of like
writing the message yeah and then what
was the other five minutes five key
insights oh sorry five key insights five
five minutes research five key insights
as a result of that research five
minutes writing the message don't spend
any longer on it move on to the next one
because otherwise you're going to be
there for ages yeah man I really like
that so just to make it even more
tangible
give me an example of what a key Insight
might be like a common key Insight that
you might use in your world one or two
key insights funding could well be the
fact that they see that they're hiring
could well be the fact that the person
that you're prospecting has just started
in a new role
um or it could well be on on the other
side of us bringing bringing it to the
table like let's say they're they're
hiring for the first time they're a
startup that we've messaged we can bring
insights that we've seen before for
example sales people especially at SDR
level are three times more likely to be
in the same company a year later if they
started with someone else at a similar
level lone sdrs in small startups
especially closer to the entry level
don't tend to work out that well so that
would be another Insight that would
share stuff that we actually have to to
prove yourself as a consultant right
clue is in the name recruitment
consultant whereas some people get
caught up in selling too much
how and just on that really quickly
because I think sometimes recruiters
aren't helped with understanding what
key insights they can offer
so how how have you helped to make sure
that your team are aware of the sort of
the Consulting that they can do if you
get what I mean yeah because sometimes
recruiters aren't they aren't they
aren't helped with that you know they're
not equipped with oh we have this data
and we can use that when we're reaching
out to people and that could be really
helpful for people to reach out to shows
that were credible shows that we're
consultant shows that were interesting
so is that something that you review on
a quarterly basis where you go hey guys
these are some of the things that we
continue to find that we can share with
our customers that would be valuable and
useful I don't know how do you make sure
that your guys and girls are equipped
with good insights that yeah you
actually have available to you the data
for the most part isn't even ours no it
isn't even ours it's stuff that you can
find online now Garden reports uh
different obviously we have the sales
communities which have been pivotal for
us actually listening to what's
happening in Tech sales right now like
we have trusted Community hosts who are
people actually in the job
which I'll come on to later when we talk
about sdr's in London but the Insight
that that delivers because at the end of
the day I'm not an SDR I can understand
it as well as I possibly can but I'm not
in the trenches doing what they're doing
day in day I'm doing something well not
completely different but quite different
so having that Insight genuine
up-to-date insight and having a tap into
your Market in that way it's completely
you know invaluable
yeah no I love that so
2019 got a top performer title yeah
how'd that feel mate oh that was good
yeah really good it was really good and
I cherished that one more because that
one is the one that actually got to go
to the end of year wise or a wise
rewards for little black tie got got my
trophy got you know my vouchers and all
of that sort of thing 2020 even though I
build more
pandemic came didn't it
pandemic came and had to enjoy the
tuxedo sitting at home I collected that
one on Zoom yeah so let's talk about
2020 then because like I've spoken to I
think we spoke about this before right
yeah
um it can be probably I don't know what
you tell me but it's more difficult to
retain that sort of top performer title
or top performer achievement than it is
to maybe get it I don't know if you
would agree with that yeah no it was it
was I think you know I said I said when
we had our prep and you know uh you know
my friend Nyle Simpson me and him went
Toe to Toe that year and it yeah it was
it was spicy right until the last week
so talk to me about so going into 2020
like how what's Lewis's mindset towards
one how are you thinking about right how
can I one improve my Billings yeah
firstly because you might have gone wow
I've achieved this didn't think I could
do that and then it's like oh no now I
like can I do more yeah so what was the
mindset in terms of like okay so how am
I now going to be able to improve on
what I've just done
um and then also then what was you
keeping um what was you keeping top of
mind to have the best chance of yeah now
you've got this label of yeah Lewis was
our top performer how are you then
dealing with that so yeah firstly how
what was top of mind to go right how can
I now continue to improve rather than
this is my level and I'm staying yeah
you know good yeah no well obviously
first and foremost going into that no
one had ever retained top biller or top
performer or whatever so obviously that
was something that I was determined to
do now that I'm there okay now's my
opportunity to do that which which is
great but look going into going into
year two going into 2020
I'm not going to sit here and say it's
solely down to all of my actions there's
always an element of luck there's always
an element of luck and in this case we
won the business one I didn't win it
personally I was part of the process but
didn't win it like single-handedly we
won a half million pound account of
which
I led and I made hay when the sun's shot
that was it that was the bottom line but
obviously I'd put myself in a position
prior to that to obviously be given the
opportunity to lead all the delivery on
it and do so on so forth so I want to
make that abundantly clear from the off
but tangible things first and foremost I
think this was the year where I stopped
like I said before being
too salesy
and actually became a consultant
especially in candidate's eyes it cannot
be I soon learned the narrative from a
candidate's perspective cannot be
Esh wants to place me in this job so he
gets money it needs to be I cannot or I
am far less likely to get this job
without hish's help hmm
and the only way that you can do that is
by first and foremost coaching is the
biggest thing so I'll come on to that in
my preparation Point shortly but
coaching
um and or coaching candidate sorry
coaching candidates yeah coaching and
by yeah also just setting an example of
right and being an expert in the process
that you're managing them in and again
that only comes going back to my
previous point of building relationships
and actually getting to know the
businesses that you're working with a a
much deeper level than just being like
his Brave crack on you know what I mean
so so that's that so that's the first
thing making sure you you you're
presented as a consultant not as
A salesperson trying to get money hmm
that's a massive narrative switch for a
candidate and a massive respect thing
secondly and this comes into the
coaching part I was talking about
preparation I think this is the year I
really nailed my candidate prep for
interviews it's a massive problem in the
industry where people just especially at
entry level when you're dealing with
grads or second job as basically do the
interview for them in a lot of sense you
think that you need to run hour-long
seminars in order to make sure the
candidate gets enough information to
nail their interview because as I said
before you can't do the interview for
them but this is as close as we can get
right this is as close as we can get but
I I didn't do that my first interview in
most cases all SDR first rounds look
pretty much the same
they're 30 minute chats with either HR
or a hiring manager cards on the table
are we compatible that sort of thing so
as soon as the first interview's booked
in my process is obviously called
candidate be like right this is booked
in for them at least 24 hours before
let's have a little 15 to 15 minutes a
half an hour prep call I'm going to send
you across some bullet points and
they're always very similar like they're
not always completely the same because
you need to adapt your process given the
client but it'll always be
I want you to come prepared to this prep
call that we're going to do with a 20
second overview of the business the
product and the problems that it solves
not like any verbatim off the website I
want to know how he's just going to say
it you know how you'd say it to to your
friend going for a walk or whatever the
second thing
I want you to come with at least three
bullet points
of why you want to work for that company
specifically not saying why you want to
be in sales not saying why you want to
be in Tech what is it specifically about
that company that gets you going you
know why you want to go is it the fact
that you've identified some awesome
progression studies from people on
LinkedIn that have been in a similar
position is it the funding is it you
know is it their branding I don't know
you know there's better reasons out
there but I want reasons specific to
that company and then lastly of course
uh specific personalized questions for
your interviewer look at their LinkedIn
profile make sure you got that you come
prepared to our prep call with all of
that and then we'll run through it and
see where you're at and that that's it
and again you're setting the precedent
to candidates it's not like okay yeah
I'm gonna send you all this stuff here
you go take a look through and we'll
have a little catch up before and then
uh good luck do you know what I mean
you've got to be like okay and then
deliver the feedback their answers
aren't good enough it'd be like cool
we need to look at this in a different
way and that's why you do it 24 hours
before because there's still time to fix
things then you do it on the morning of
it's too late
that's great insight there so in terms
of yeah leading into to coaching people
through the process yeah anything else
that just on that coach piece anything
else that Lewis the consultant can coach
candidates on or that you would put
under that sort of Coach title that
great recruitment Consultants do yeah
they're coaching on their career you
know these types of things yeah look I
mean
I think it's completely
important to immerse yourself in the
market that you're selling into I most
of the time being honest don't feel like
I work in recruitment I feel like I work
in Tech sales even though I'm not but we
are consistently doing events with that
market I know you know a lot of the a
lot of the LinkedIn top voices like Tom
Boston and all of those sorts of people
and you know Morgan Ingram's now doing
the Elites for us our awards ceremony in
may like these are all people that I can
call upon and message at any one time
just spending time with those people and
delivering getting the insight and
almost feeling like you work in the
market that you're selling into as
opposed to recruitment
that that was a big mindset switch for
me and and yeah that that coaching piece
specifically for recruitment Consultants
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincere and saucebreaker because you
listen to this podcast you were able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're a growing recruitment business
you have to check out Vin Cherry who are
an all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
tools on the market to stand out and
beat their competition then you have to
check out Source breaker use the link in
the show notes in the comments below and
you'll be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products yeah
that enables you to then offer the
insights right so so let's talk about
because I want to go into sdr's London
right so
but let's talk about let's just focus
for a second on Lewis being a playing
manager because you've been doing it for
a while and this is really tough and
really difficult for a lot of people
um it's interesting I'll speak in to
some recruiters uh recently who uh top
performers and sort of feel like uh well
they sort of learn quite quickly that
they just didn't like management so a
lot of people listen to this have either
been forced into management or the only
way at the moment in their sort of
career Pathways in their business they
can evolve their creative by going into
management being a play manager right
so I guess why don't we start with like
when Lewis wasn't if we've been honest
like not that great learning as you were
going failing not being a great pedo
manager but then you were learning from
that to become a better one what was you
doing then that's like different but now
in terms of like you being better are
you doing definitely so let's just start
with maybe what was Lewis doing the you
looking back
if we're being honest you wasn't being
the best player manager or the the
greatest player manager anything there
to share that you had to learn the hard
way yeah sure I think I think the
biggest thing uh is that
in terms of eras of my team I'm probably
now in Era three okay so there's been
three in in my mind obviously they all
didn't leave at the same time there's
not like two mass exoduses since uh
since that but there's been sort of
three turnovers key Turners with my team
the first two and this is comes down to
recruitment right for yourself for your
own team
I love them to bits we still get along
today I employed the wrong people I
employed the wrong people my first team
was have said effectively a team of
intercepted candidates because we'd do
that obviously we're working a market
that was that was similar at an entry
level commercial go to market sales job
whatever you want to call it uh they
come into wiser HQ which as you know is
pretty sick and then and then
they just fall in love with the culture
and they'll be like you know what yeah I
can get down with a bit of recruitment I
can do that yeah we could do that and
then it's not the right reasons going
back to what I said at the start a lot
of my first team love them but they
didn't they didn't need to make it work
they could walk into many other jobs you
know they were well educated uh good
grades that the world was their oyster
um obviously they were very good at
recruitment as well you know that helped
what we employed them but like you know
they were they were great but when you
obviously work in a market where you're
placing a candidate similar to yourself
on more money a bit of a recipe for
disaster so I do so firstly maybe got it
wrong the first time got it wrong got it
wrong and so you know just because they
speak well
um you know they they're obviously
intelligent and they like the look of
what you're offering doesn't necessarily
necessarily mean they're going to be
right long term and and that's exactly
how it played out got a year out of most
of them and then they moved on to other
things is predominantly tech companies
you know as well into into SDR positions
and that sort of thing second year of my
team was was then just completely ripped
apart by the pandemic not not much we
could do there some learnings of course
um which I'll keep to myself but at the
same time like yeah it's just nothing's
nothing you could do and then we started
the what I call third era which was with
uh with me and Lauren uh and then and
then we built things out from there and
then it's a mixture of experienced
recruiters not necessarily in the tech
sales Market but then also the right the
right grads the grads that that that
have something to prove and you know
they can't just go anywhere else and and
give up when it gets hard like they've
proven that they can and need to make it
work and that's been pretty damn
successful so far so and then love that
and then and then Lewis as a manager
yeah what what was you not doing maybe
not so great at yeah good I think I
think initially and the whole we have a
big culture at wiser of reporting down
which
means in plain English just because
you're a manager you don't sit in your
Ivory Tower and you tell people what to
do and you set them standard for them
but you you know you're you're in
manager land your head of Department
you're an associate director you don't
need to do the same thing as that now we
get rid of that balls to that every week
at the start of each week and now I've
given it given the T the responsibility
to my team to lead that meeting every
week as well so it's not just me doing
it all the time but we will set
objectives or goals for the week not
nothing major four or five and they
could well be like okay I'm gonna wrap
up this deal this week I'm gonna get
five first interviews at this particular
client I'm going to secure a new job or
at least generate a new client meeting
uh two LinkedIn posts and yeah you know
for example for me today was to come on
here and absolutely smash him and then
uh and then
what we do is we review that on
Wednesday we have our goals pit stop in
the morning go through it all and we'll
Market traffic light system green is it
achieved Amber not achieved yet red lost
it
that's that and we keep yourself
accountable and I my goals go in there
all the time do I get full green every
time absolutely not not every week I did
last week though and everyone knew about
it
um but look reporting down I think is
the the biggest respect Builder that you
can do if you're not proving that you
can perform at the same or a better
level than than your team then then why
are you why are you their manager like
you need to prove that consistently I
mean because because that's what that's
what does it and I'm not saying I wasn't
doing that to begin with but I probably
just wasn't externalizing it as much as
I could so my advice would be to anyone
who's a player manager or a manager
right now show the team What You're Made
Of
so on this then if we can go granular
for a sec yeah so you mentioned Monday
kickoff for the week love that I'm
probably gonna steal that I'll do
something similar but I like the
Wednesday pit stop I think I could do
that better rather than like a morning
call yeah I think that I really I'm
gonna steal the Wednesday pit stop
that's a good one so just to get a
granted for a second I speak to a lot of
playing managers uh billing managers who
do find it really hard not to get pulled
Pillar To Post Yeah so I guess if we if
it's cool with you like could we just
break down a bit like Lewis's typical
week I know you're super organized yeah
um obviously you could there's only so
much you can plan for and like if I'm in
your team and I need help I'm assuming
you're going to help me right um if
there's like something I really need
your advice on whatever but what how do
you try and set up your week to make
sure that Lewis can lead by example yep
and you're doing
um yeah you're trying to lead by example
and you're doing what you're doing so
hitting your number performing you're
also being the manager
um and you're making sure that people
know that if they need help so support
Lewis is there and then it sounds like
you're doing some of the accountability
stuff as a manager with what you just
described so yeah talk to us a bit about
what maybe like a typical week would
look like where yeah how you try and set
that up so you're not just pulled Pillar
To Post and it's not like Lewis I need
to help this Lewis I need to help with
that and you're like now I need
to get this done I haven't been able to
do you know what I mean yeah how have
you approached that over over the years
yeah good well first and foremost let's
talk about my own personal performance
yeah right you you mentioned this in the
post yesterday which we went through in
the prep so
many recruiters will block out times in
their Diaries to do particular tasks I'm
gonna spend three hours resourcing for
this particular role I'm going to spend
two hours doing business development
but what does that actually mean like
you know what I mean what I've the
biggest mindsets which and and thing
that I've seen with my own team as well
in getting them to do it is let's make a
small tangible Target for that time
frame and if it doesn't get done we know
for well we need to make it up somewhere
you know what I mean so for example I'm
going to build a project of at least 30
great candidates within this hour-long
period and they're all getting the first
message
okay I'm gonna put
um 10 excellent prospects into our CRM
system and they're all going to get a
first message within this two hour
period you know all of that sort of
thing
rather than being two hours of BD
to as resourcing set small tangible
goals that will set you on your way to
obviously your weekly kpi or Target so
that's that's how we do that and that's
how I keep myself accountable moving
forward in terms of the team being a
manager
um
I think it's important to Pivot because
hits the fan right you can't just
in an Ideal World you'd do the same
thing same schedule every week that that
doesn't always work we have the skeleton
of my diary it's very color coded as you
can imagine so all everything yellow in
my diary is internal meetings everything
blue is sort of uh tasks that I need to
do could well be a candidate call could
well be
um replying to this person chasing up
this person you know task bits and Bobs
that I need to do throughout the day
green stuff is community focused purple
is business development all of that sort
of thing I always make sure that there
is because you have in I don't know if
everyone uses Google Calendar but you
have like uh a little bar of how much
time being being used I keep an eye on
that massively yeah it's good good
little insight it is I look as I looked
I looked at it two weeks ago and I was
like me
seventy percent of my week is yellow
which means it's internal meeting yeah
so you can change that like we need to
change that straight away
um and that's just the the way in which
I can keep myself accountable moving
forward and be like okay what can I do
here is this meeting vital
do I you know do I need to be in this or
can can this be done in an out of room
setting and just making sure that I'm
keeping myself accountable for for doing
my tasks and hitting my numbers
personally as well but that said
I used to do all of my one-to-ones on a
Monday morning Monday morning at wiser
is meeting C there's meetings left right
I think it is for a lot of businesses
right you don't I don't actually start
work until Monday at half one I would
say yeah but um
one thing I pivoted recently because I
always felt like we were we were missing
things on a Monday morning there was
don't be wrong everyone's busy heads
down but there's still opportunities out
there there's still messages that that
were coming in that if we respond too
quickly that we were going to win over a
competitor or or whatever else it may be
and
I pivoted so as opposed to just doing
15-minute almost speed date one-to-ones
with my team
I then changed that to right okay
because the team were like we would
always feel like we're on a bit of a
rush and we can't really dig into things
and I agreed I was like we can't delve
into your numbers properly we can't I
can't delve into your pipeline properly
I can't advise you on every sort of
granular detail and what we can what we
can do
um so we shifted it so now I have a half
hour one to one every day every day
throughout the week yeah wow throughout
the week so rather than blocking out an
entire not not every day with everyone I
mean like for example obviously I have
four team members oh so in four days you
have a half an hour
that is not a good use of my time yeah
um God love them rather than it being
Monday or Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday rather than all being Monday
one block and I don't end up coming up
for air until about half one two on a
Monday afternoon we'll do yeah we'll do
something with like Darius on a Monday
we'll have nursery on a Tuesday uh
Sheldon on a Wednesday we're here on
Thursday something like that so we'll do
that and then everyone gets a a proper
yeah one and doing it that way you don't
always have to do things the way they've
been done yeah and I think me being that
organized always
that was probably the downfall of of
that and something that I've recently
come to terms with that being like yeah
just because this is how it's always
done this is how it's always worked but
it's the best way like getting yourself
into a funk sometimes you've got to
freshen things up and pivot a little bit
in terms of your organization that's a
great insight and I think that with that
being the setup I guess the the kickoff
at the beginning of the week super
important then isn't it to have that
because you don't want anyone feeling
like they're not set up for the week not
if they need a bit of help on what they
need to focus on all these things you've
got that Monday kickoff these are our
goals and then the one-on-ones are like
I'm assuming Lewis how are you getting
on yeah can I help you with anything
what more can I do to support you and
then there might be some accountability
stuff going on yeah it's good and then
just on that as well the last thing I'd
probably say that
was a big struggle in the beginning of
becoming a player manager was not doing
the job for them hmm like
2018 Lewis or whenever it was I started
man I think I had my first intern in
2017 but
when someone just asked a question it's
easy just go ah it just come here
I'll do it I mean you write this write
this do this or you know whereas in
actual fact what managers should be
doing is challenging their team
so you come to me and be like Lewis
obviously this is the situation and you
know x y and Zed the the candidate has
has not come back not confirmed the
interview what do you think we should do
I'm like well what do you think we
should do
what do you think we should do and then
nine times out of ten they'll come out
with the answer it's almost like a
validation thing especially when you've
got you've got people who are early on
your career in their careers in your
team it's all just a validation thing
and the quicker you can break that habit
the easier your life's gonna be yeah no
no I'm always mindful of that
um I've been yeah not just doing it for
people I think yeah that's a great
Insight so let's spend the last 10
minutes then talking about sdrs of
London I think I do respect that
obviously no Jack
um well I do feel like I'd say most most
recruitment companies outside looking in
your space will go you know what wise
has done a really good job of building a
community and Community there's no it is
a huge part of that as well he is yes
he's great
um so yeah talk to me about why don't we
just start which could be helpful for
people
um what would you say because how long
um Esters of London how long have you
been doing that for three years three
years cool principles of making that
success principles of building a
successful Community talk to me about
that yeah sure just to give everyone
I'll give everyone a bit of insights to
what bloody hella actually is first for
people that don't know so sdr's London
is is an inclusive peer-to-peer
mentorship Community for lead generators
at tech companies based in in the
capital although we do tend to have
people that come from at home counties
and here they're in everywhere it's very
popular with remote sdrs as well because
they only have teams to like bounce off
or get advice from so so that's what it
is the it's effectively a WhatsApp group
for the most part that's how it started
started with 15 sdrs that had placed 15
sdrs at companies that I'd quite like to
work with uh put them all into a
WhatsApp thread and went there you go
Mentor each other for free and Network
and and that's exactly what happened and
we went from 30 members to about 120
members in a week we now have over five
and a half thousand and followers on
LinkedIn 1200 members either in WhatsApp
or mailing list and we are consistent
with doing an event with air call next
week for example which is sponsored
event and should on track to be a
sellout
um and that will be a minimum of at
least 100 people in our office next
Thursday all all doing that so but it's
not that it's very easy when I say it
that way yeah
it's hard you know yourself you know
yourself
um it wasn't always that way and along
the last three years it would have been
very easy to sell out at some point so
in the beginning everyone was like I'm
putting all these sdrs at this WhatsApp
thread inviting them and everyone's
looking at me like
something yeah what's his recruit
they're trying to put us all into
WhatsApp Fred what the is he
playing at anyway
um and it took time it took time to
build trust
um and it took a lot of willpower to not
just be like oh my god I've got a gold
mine of Canada I would love to run this
run this little roll past should be good
um I didn't stayed strong we didn't sell
out any point I've never posted a job in
there ever and and I think that's what
built the trust the other thing so first
and foremost just to summarize don't do
not sell out do not sell out don't don't
take the easy transactional win
you need to build something cool you
need to build something that's respected
that's going to add value to people not
just your own personal gain
um secondly you need Advocates of what
you're doing like for example I know
with recruitment mentors and and sort of
the the platform that you have you have
um you know hosts or people that come in
and do particular things exactly the
same for us I am not an SDR
I cannot even though I understand pretty
damn well I'd like to think about the
day-to-day of an SDR there's still
certain nuances and things that I can't
do and at the end of the day I've never
been one I can't relate to their
problems I haven't sat in the sea I
haven't walked a mile in their shoes so
from that pretty early on I realized
that we need some we need some Advocates
on the ground people that understand
wiser people that know that we're not in
this for the wrong reasons and that we
can put as Leaders within the community
that the wider SDR Community can come to
and obviously there are experienced sdrs
the first ones we had were Ben Smith
that reached this Jack Nico sales Loft
uh will gay at cognizm all of those
sorts of people and they were just well
well respected him on the community and
that was a game changer as well and
that's really what then set us on a
trajectory because there was then that
extra layer of people that fully
understood
knew I wasn't there just to to try and
you know make the world's best talent
pool
um
but that was it they were the two key
things I would say were super successful
and then set us on the right and then
let's just be real though right you
you've you've the thing good like
Revenue
um Revenue can be attributed to Asia's
London of course yeah no absolutely of
course and you know you know we did I
didn't like don't be wrong first and
foremost it's there to help the sdrs
yeah but what's the byproduct yeah it
goes back to my shop window analogy
we're always in the shop window now
we're in the shop window for for most of
the the tech Market because people
especially among the sales functions
people know us we've got
um we've got so many people in our
communities now across because it's not
just sdrs of London yeah you've got
different ones the sdrs and sdrs of
London started getting good and getting
promoted to AES so we have to create AES
of London and started addressing issues
about emerging account Executives people
transitioning into that role we had the
elite for sales leadership and go to
market leaders and we've now got making
moves Which is less so helping you along
your career more so a catalyst for
change it's our women in Tech sales
community did the other week around
um well say the other week it was just
before Christmas around maternity leave
and being an individual contributor
because obviously when you go on on mat
leave you lose your OTE which is like
it's Madness so it's more of a catalyst
for change that one and trying to
educate the industry but yeah with
regards to doing all of those sorts of
things you do something good for people
they will want to do something good for
you but you your heart's got to be pure
yeah 100 but like let's just be real
right like that's it's good so like I'm
assuming I'm you can tell me but I'm
assuming you would have had moments
where people would have reached out to
England Lewis I've actually been part of
the community for ages and I actually
would love some career advice or
actually it might be and then you might
work with them right so that's something
and then also it's going to impact BD
it's a it's a differentiator it's Lewis
I've seen what you guys are doing
investors in London like like you're the
type of recruiter that I want to sort of
partner with you're probably gonna be
really close to what it is that people
want so I'm assuming it's going to help
with BD right and then and then you just
said that who are sponsoring so then
there can potentially end up being if
the partnership's right some Revenue
generating opportunities absolutely that
can be directly attributed so yeah cool
yeah no we're not just doing it
completely obviously you know it makes
commercial sense to do so but it's been
a long-term build to get it this year
yeah but it's coming from not selling
out early not selling out early being in
the shop window being seen to be doing
the the doing the right things for the
right reasons and then obviously yes of
course it's an unrivaled referral
Network for work and candidates yeah
and then before we finish then just on
that because I'm going to make it clear
because I I do really I think what you
guys are doing is great so start over
what's that group yeah
like now what has it been coming from
outside looking and it looks like you
create intentional learning events or
yeah events if it's like virtual or in
person obviously I know you guys utilize
your office space which is absolutely
awesome so if you ended up basically
obviously besides the what's happened
getting other people to speak to
like-minded people it's then you're
putting on some sort of learning events
for around things that a lot of the
community want help with yeah is that
pretty much it gotta be current to the
time it's got to be relevant for example
the air call event is doing more with
less in the current climate around sdrs
so we've got uh heads of sales
development SDR manager speaking from
some great Brands like fresh relevance
cognizum
um obviously air call as well
um but and also Source whale you'll know
got Lucy from Source whale speaking as
well but um but it's just all about it's
got to be relevant it's got to be in the
time and it's got to be there to service
the community and help them with what
they're doing if all of a sudden you
know a company came to us and being like
we want to sell more subscription so we
want to sponsor you for an event we're
like yeah it's not going to work
unfortunately we'd love you money of
course we would but that's just that's
not going to wash with the team that'd
be selling out you know I mean we're not
going to do that it needs to be relevant
it needs to help
its audience that's that's sort of the
the key thing but we'll do an in-person
event every quarter per Community an
online event every quarter per community
and then yeah if anyone else wants to
step up you get people from the
community all the time that want to
improve their personal brand and do all
of that sort of thing and we're more
than happy to give them that platform if
they want to take a chance and do it and
that's to be honest with you that's how
a lot of people come
Community House for us hmm love it well
at Lewis absolutely loved going into all
that I think um just to round it off I
think 25 Rod Lewis would definitely be
proud of what you've built and no doubt
what you're going to continue to go on
um yeah love your energy mate love your
passion and uh thank you so much coming
on the Pod hey thanks for having me a
bit of blast thank you so much for
listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode